turns out cancer culture has another
casualties and this time it's you a new
study finds americans are censoring
themselves on how they really feel about
hot button issues take a look at this
chart ceos going woke on social issues
schools focusing on racism too much mask
effective stopping covid people would
publicly say they agree with each of
those seemingly popular stances but
privately they're not so sure but it's
uncomfortable out there greg in the
world you got a self-censor well here's
the deal self-censorship is part of life
if you said everything you thought you
you would be me and it's not pleasant
you're gonna say yeah what's some
pleasure to the people around me it's
getting me in a lot of trouble but so
it's good but that's being polite right
having manners but also not calling out
people that's the difference with with
canceled culture is it's about calling
out people and then being immune from
any kind of discussion afterwards like i
am the victim you are the oppressor and
then they can't shut up about themselves
and what it does it's kind of dangerous
when you think about it if you remove
conversation there's what's left right
you can you can have complete alienation
or you can have violence you could say
like oh this person had this person is
expressing inflammatory language on the
five that shouldn't worry you at all
what should worry you is if we stop
talking right because if we stop talking
that means we're gonna do something
really bad because we're gonna go back
to our little underground caves and plan
things i think the solution to defy self
cancellation if you're young is to get
so good at something that you can leave
if your company gets super woke you can
leave and that's happening right now
when you see the woke workers at disney
or google or or publishing they're
generally the least competent because
they can't leave the company so you get
this kind of like idiot kernel
a center of dumbness now in every
company and it's all the people that
can't leave that's true that's true it's
interesting because you don't
self-censor very much judge
you don't know
that's probably true but i'm sure you've
probably heard from people that come up
to you and say i love the show i love
listening to you because sometimes you
say things i think that i won't say
right yeah but you know um
i'm i'm just a straight shooter it's
just who i am and maybe it's from whence
i come i mean i was a woman in a man's
world and you know i'm older too but
what uh you were too yes did you trans
yeah yeah
but you know what i think is interesting
today in schools they're they're they're
not teaching our kids to think
so they're teaching an ideology and
they're teaching this group thing we all
think this this is what you must think
so right now we're raising a whole
generation of young kids who are thought
to think the same way their peers think
so while we can think independently and
and you know and be that bright person
who can break from the mob i'm not sure
that the kids who are coming up now
are going to be able to be that
independent because they haven't been
taught how to debate how to think you
know you're not allowed to say things
what did you pick up when you read this
article i was thinking about
vaccinations for kids which is one of
the new frontiers for this i mean we've
all generally accepted the vaccine is a
good thing to have because you can still
get covey but you will be less sick than
if you didn't have covid but now you
have vaccines available for kids you
know six months to
five years of age and parents are not
vaccinating their kids and they were
happy to take the vaccine themselves and
but they feel uncomfortable doing it
they don't feel like there's necessarily
enough information or that frankly their
kids need it because it hasn't been
shown to be that destructive obviously
there are cases of kids who have passed
away and all of that but i find that to
be the most interesting part of this
because i have a ton of liberal friends
and we were all you know first in line
when it was our turn to get vaccinated
and there's big concerns over why it's
necessary or what happened and that
myocarditis study out of thailand yes
about teenage boys i don't know why we
didn't do that study here in the u.s it
seems like a pretty big deal if the
second dose of the pfizer vaccine i
think was the pfizer one was leading to
this big uptick in cases sean i wanted
to ask you do you think members of
congress are guilty not guilty of this
but practice this sort of
self-censorship like would they say god
i can't believe we're actually saying
this and then they'd actually have to
say something else i think they do that
by less than the average public but i
think this is a one-way street it's the
left that tries to censor the right the
right does very little about censoring
you know liberals no it's true and so
you you all of a sudden jessica you all
of a sudden
you have the majority that now things
for
the minority thinks they're the majority
and so when you're actually afraid of
losing your job or being shamed socially
or being excluded you will curtail your
beliefs and if your ideas are so bad
like democrats ideas are you need to
shut up the conversation you need to
cancel people or shame people on twitter
you can't let people debate these things
because if they do the american people
go this is horrible i don't want to go
in this direction i don't want to be
transient or transitioning you know 12
year old kids i don't want to be giving
my 8 year old child a vaccine there's a
whole bunch of things that we should
debate that we won't and they silence us
because that's how they get the bad
ideas into politics but to be fair i'm
going to
defend you in the sense that
we were like that i think this has been
a huge switch it used to be that in the
in the republicans remember they were
puritanical they were they was very they
were pretty close minded on a lot of
things and and then they have you seen a
flip the left used to be about freedom
of speech the right and not so much and
it's flipped now we're all about speech
they might have been closed-minded
that's true but they weren't trying to
silence the left the silence had free
reign to say what they remember well and
they controlled all the platforms on
which to say it book ban lists that are
going on right now out of republicans by
the way the left is not the ones even
though they were it goes back and forth
i would say um just practice some grace
and non-judgment all right hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now